is the 10,000 hour rule actually true
we'll find out in this video so
originally asked a question for one of
my YouTube viewers Sally love you guys
how many hours per day would you
recommend to work at a particular skill
in total per week to become outstanding
at something so while ago in this famous
book outliers Malcolm Gladwell came up
with a 10,000 hour rule his theory was
that if you spend 10,000 hours working
on something then you would get to
master class level he use examples of
the Beatles who toured Germany in the
early sixties and built up their 10,000
hours of practice and Bill Gates who got
his first computer as a young teenager
and spent over 10,000 hours programming
on it but do you actually need to spend
10,000 hours to become world-class at a
particular skill so here are my three
thoughts on it number one your passion
matters you can spend hours and hours
and hours and hours working at something
and if you're not passionate about it
you're not going to become master class
level just think about when you're in
school there are some subjects that you
love and some subjects that you hated
and no matter how much time you spent on
the subject you hated your growth would
grow so slowly and painfully but the
subjects that you loved and will
generally interested in you would learn
so much faster and that's a problem with
most people today they're working the
jobs that they hate they graduated with
whatever degree entered the workforce
and they spend 10 20 30 40 50 years
working at a company that they hate you
can spend 10 years at a company and
never get that big promotion never get
to be the CEO or anywhere close to it
even though you spent the ten thousand
hours plus 20 thousand hours 30 thousand
hours you're never getting to that level
where you want to be because you're not
passionate enough about it if you are
genuinely interested in the subject
you're learning you're going to pick it
up much more quickly than if you're
forced to do something that you hate
number two is not all hours are the same
the fastest way to pick something up the
fastest way to learn a new skill is to
model success get a coach get a trainer
get a teacher get somebody
show you the ropes the slowest way to
figure something out is to try to
understand that yourself and make all
the mistakes that people have already
made so 10,000 hours trying to struggle
to figure it all out for yourself may be
equivalent to 500 hours of being taught
by professional and how to do it I look
back on my youtube channel as an example
in my first videos I didn't really know
what I was doing I was experimenting I
was trying to do everything myself
and my first videos are really really
really bad and slowly I got better but
it was a slow crawl forward go look back
on my channel and you'll see years and
years of just slow development and then
when I met Jamie who's my media coach
she trained me on how to get better and
within a couple months I was already
seen significant growth on my channel
now I still worked hard I'm still
putting in the effort I'm still applying
everything that she's teaching me and as
a result the growth in my development
the growth in my subscribers a growth in
my views on each video has grown
tremendously
so not all hours are created equal if
you model success and learn from the
best you'll achieve results a lot faster
than someone who tries to do everything
themselves and my third point is why do
you really care and I ask this because
if you're asking how many hours it takes
to get really good at something how many
hours you need to dedicate in your week
to to get good at this particular skill
then it kind of tells you that you're
not really that interested in learning
the skill if you really want to get
better at something then you should feel
like you're getting lost in it like you
could wake up in the morning and start
working on it and then look up and it's
already 6 o'clock at night and you're
not keeping track of the hours to say
only a hundred more hours until I get
really good at this
it's like someone who starts a business
just trying to make a lot of money you
find that they never do they struggle
they struggle they struggle they tell
themself if I keep this struggle up
adventure I'm going to make my millions
of dollars but they never get there
because they never loved it in the first
place you should want to get better at
that skill it should drive you it should
feel you should make you happy and
excited to learn and get better and if
you have a number in your head that
that's your end goal like when I get to
number of hours I'm going to be really
good and then I'm going to achieve
success that's the wrong way to look at
it instead you should find a skill or a
goal that you really want to get better
at something where you stop tracking the
hours something that you can really have
a positive impact on the world with and
if that's your intention and you work
hard at it you will achieve masterclass
low believe I love to know what your
thoughts are leave a comment below let
me know how cause a little bit of a
controversy or not here and if you like
this video you want to see more don't
forget to subscribe to the channel thank
you so much for watching I'll see you
soon self-improvement books are like
Fitness books they never work on their
own what you need is a trainer that's
Evan gab the newsletter
you